[Music]
new york city has skyscrapers of all
shapes and sizes
but why does this 500 foot tall 29 story
building have no windows
no lights and no markings at all well
because it's a top secret nsa spy
station
built to withstand nuclear war let's
find out why
[Applause]
[Music]
new york city architecture covers
everything art deco gothic art nouveau
renaissance revival in the 1950s
a style emerged called brutalism and
brutalist architecture is known for
focusing on function over form and
minimalism but there's one brutalist
building in new york that's so
minimalist
that has been called the most mysterious
building in new york it's 33 thomas
street
and it's a 500 foot tall skyscraper with
no exterior lighting
and has no windows what 33 thomas street
does have
is secrets officially this is an att
telecommunications building
but thanks to leaked documents we now
know that 33 thomas street is actually a
top secret nsa mass surveillance hub
its code name is titan point and right
now as we speak
titan point is listening the 1960s was
the height of the cold war
everyone thought nuclear war was
imminent so the us
desperate to protect its infrastructure
launched a secret project called
project x project x you're kidding right
no that's what it was called
they're usually more creative the goal
of project x
was to build a skyscraper in the middle
of new york city capable of withstanding
a nuclear blast
the building would be 29 floors have no
windows
three basement levels and enough food to
last
1500 people two weeks but its primary
purpose was not to protect humans
this would be a fortress designed to
protect computers and telecommunications
equipment
operated by at t for two years secret
documents leaked by former national
security contractor edward snowden
have yielded a steady stream of news
reports about u.s
government spying on terrorism suspects
foreign leaders
and american citizens now another
chapter has been revealed how
telecommunications giant a t
demonstrated a quote extreme willingness
to help the nsa
the building was designed by john karl
warnicky and construction began in 1969
and was completed in 1974.
the gray granite tower is located at 33
thomas street in lower manhattan
and locals know the building as the long
lines building and it's been a source of
mystery for years
what jumps out is that the building has
no windows and no exterior lighting
so during the day it kind of fades into
the background of the new york city
skyline
at night it becomes an invisible shadow
now thanks to nsa documents leaked by
edward snowden
we now know that creating an invisible
building wasn't an accident
it was absolutely by design
it's not unusual to keep locations
containing vital telecommunications
equipment a secret
hundreds of millions of phone calls and
faxes go through 33 thomas street
every day but 33 thomas street has
another level of secrecy
it also appears to be one of the most
important national security agency
surveillance sites
on u.s soil a secret monitoring hub that
is used to tap into phone calls
faxes and internet data 33 thomas street
operates under nsa code name titan point
and titan point is a core location used
for controversial
and possibly illegal nsa sponsored mass
surveillance
according to leaked documents this
program has targeted the communications
of the un
the world bank the imf it's been used to
spy on at least 38 countries
including u.s allies like france germany
and japan
now it's common knowledge that att is
very cooperative with the nsa
if you're using an att cell phone you
might want to rethink that
the depth of cooperation between the
agency and telecommunications company at
t the documents reveal the company
allowed the nsa access
to billions of client emails as well as
phone call metadata the emails were
accessible to analysts on a keyword
search basis
i use a burner nice but because of the
snowden documents
we can now see just how much the nsa and
att have been
integrated any phone call fax or piece
of data that comes through the network
the nsa can easily capture it the
government knows who you're calling and
when
they know how long you talk and what
keywords you say now
legally the nsa can only target the
communications of foreign nationals
but all the equipment is there it's
already working
so do you think the nsa really stops
listening when it determines that you're
a us citizen
exactly if you could give me a yes or no
answer to the question
does the nsa collect any type of data
at all on millions or hundreds of
millions of americans
no sir it does not
not wittingly there are cases where
they could inadvertently perhaps
uh collect but not not wittingly
the code name titan point is all over
the nsa documents
usually found in classified reports
about surveillance ops
nsa uses code names to conceal
information that it considers
especially sensitive and there are
secret nsa travel guides that reveal
that titan point is actually 33 thomas
street
but you have to kind of piece it
together one guide was written to help
nsa employees visiting facilities around
the country
this guide discloses that titan point is
in new york city
another travel guide written a little
later states that an nsa corporate
partner code name
lithium supervises the site and lithium
we know now
is nsa's code name for at t another
document
reveals that titan point is a short walk
away from the fbi field office
in fact from the front steps of 33
thomas you can see the fbi building it's
about two blocks away
so yeah this is the place now when
visiting titan point
protocol is to arrange your visit
through the fbi field office
you should then hire a cover vehicle
through the fbi especially if you're
bringing in equipment
the nsa would like you to remain in
cover during your visit so please do not
display any nsa badge or insignia
simply ring the buzzer sign in have a
seat and wait
someone will be right down but what's
actually going on inside
well if you're a fan of privacy freedom
and the constitution
you're not going to like it no no
in 1975 just a year after 33 thomas
street was completed
the nsa found themselves in hot water a
congressional inquiry showed that the
nsa
was spying on anti-vietnam war activists
that's not legal is it
it's not according to the fourth
amendment the government can't gather
data on you without a warrant
signed by a judge a judge isn't going to
sign a warrant without the suspicion of
a crime
being against a war isn't a crime so
rather than bother a judge
they just started collecting data on all
kinds of people
like prominent leaders of the civil
rights movement like dr king muhammad
ali was targeted
anti-war journalists and columnists
working at the washington post and new
york times
were targeted surveilled spied on after
this scandal
congress created the foreign
intelligence surveillance act which you
might have heard referred to as fisa
now fisa limits surveillance to foreign
nationals and agents of foreign powers
and under fisa the executive branch must
request
warrants from a newly formed fisa court
i bet the nsa hated these new rules
they did did they at least follow the
rules oh man
law didn't seem to have stopped the nsa
according to an annual report released
recently despite having fisa warrants to
spy on only 42 specific terrorism
suspects
last year the national security agency
managed to collect
151 million american phone call records
what is the nsa doing and does it
justify the massive violation of your
privacy
the leaked nsa documents exposed an nsa
surveillance program
codenamed blarney blarney was
established in the early 1970s
and as far as we know it's still
operating blarney specifically leverages
commercial
partnerships like the one with a t that
allows the nsa to gain access to global
networks
blarney is what's called a full take
surveillance program
meaning it collects not just metadata
like who you're calling and when
but full content like what you're saying
and what you're doing online now as of
the time of the leak
the nsa had obtained at least 40 fisa
court orders for spying under project
blarney
now targets were major banks around the
world all kinds of companies
and 38 countries they also targeted the
united nations
did the u.n find out of course they did
and they weren't pleased about it but
what's the us going to say
the data coming from blarney was landing
in the president's daily briefing
both republicans and democrats there's
not much of a difference between those
two
there's not but if there's one thing all
presidents can agree on
is that they love spying on their
enemies both foreign and domestic
no more illegal wiretapping of american
citizens
no more national security letters to spy
on citizens who are not suspected of a
crime
no more tracking citizens who do nothing
more than protest
a misguided war so instead let's track
every citizen the project blarney
running out of titan point in new york
is one of three key nsa locations that
actually captures data from software
like skype and zoom
and 33 thomas street is one of only a
few att
buildings with an fcc satellite license
so the nsa not only captures data coming
through landlines
but also vacuums up data from space this
type of expansive surveillance creates a
ton of data that has to go somewhere
so enter project skid row
[Applause]
skid row is a program that allows nsa
employees to search through huge
quantities of user data like
actual emails online chat message boards
texts
passwords even people's browser history
this data is all being collected
right now and how much of that data is
legally collected well there's no way to
know for sure there's really not a lot
of oversight
but an agency like the nsa needs to be
watched
i mean remember how the nsa hacked
google and yahoo and we're secretly
capturing all the data inside those
private
clouds what oh you don't know that one
well that's another video but always
assume that if you're online
you're being watched any intelligence
service in the world can own that phone
the minute it connects to their network
as soon as you turn it on
it can be theirs they can turn it into a
microphone they can take pictures from
it
they can take the data off now at
t is far from the only corporate
relationship the nsa has
the agency has established at least 80
corporate partnerships that we're aware
of
but some companies are more cooperative
than others att
is notorious for being on very friendly
terms with the government the new york
times and others have reported that at
t has given billions of emails to the
nsa
a range of evidence including technical
terms specific to at t
points to the company being the nsa's
partner the documents refer to the
company being
highly collaborative and commend its
extreme willingness to help
and this has been corroborated by a
whistleblower who's part of a
class-action lawsuit against the nsa
but george bush simply disregarded the
face of law
and approved it all on his own signature
which was totally illegal
i might add that while there are a few
dissidents in both parties like
rand paul in the republican side and
ron wyden on the democratic side is that
both parties
approve this when they passed the
immunity bill for the phone companies
in 2008 with the help of barack obama i
might add
um and that killed the lawsuit the case
is joule v nsa which was filed almost 15
years ago
and still going on in 2017 a judge
ordered the nsa to provide evidence
proving or denying that it spied on at t
customers
did they provide it nah they appealed
still in court
still well it's taking so long ah you
know
all of it i'm getting tired of that as
an excuse
titan point is just one location
according to the snowden documents
at t has installed surveillance
equipment in at least 59 u.s locations
and on any given day nsa employees are
on site
gathering data now what's crazy is that
until this leak
most att employees probably weren't
aware of the nsa's presence
nsa operatives are instructed to blend
in with other workers
they would simply show up go into an
office or a server room and go to work
just like everybody else all of this
should be pretty chilling
america's secret agencies firmly
subscribe to
it's better to ask forgiveness than
permission and the nsa
cia the fbi and others are very willing
to bend the rules
interpret and even break laws to suit
their purposes
all in the name of national security now
to paraphrase ben franklin
when you trade liberty for security you
end up with neither
and there are many other companies like
att google facebook
that cooperate with the government with
such a lack of friction
that any american citizen should be
concerned those long agreements that you
sign online without reading them
every once in a while read one take note
of how many of your rights you're
surrendering
for the convenience of being able to
post pictures of your cat or leave a
mean comment on a video
as we willingly surrender more of our
privacy to digital conglomerates
we're also surrendering freedoms like
the freedom from illegal searches and
spying
like the freedom to criticize the
government the freedom to publicly
disagree with popular ideas
we are guilty of being complicit in this
erosion of our freedoms
and once freedoms are fully eroded well
that's called slavery
i can't promise we're not already there
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files
if you had fun or learned anything today
do me a favor and like subscribe
comment and share the algorithm is
probably part of an nsa surveillance
program
but with your help we can defeat it i
can't wait though
probably not but until next time be safe
be kind
and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
you